i'm very you know thrilled to be
in this life in this privilege that i
have
of this work and everything that goes
with it
cloris leachman has died a rep for the
legendary actress confirmed to et
cloris died in her sleep tuesday night
she was 94.
cloris prolific career spanned decades
acting in more than 100 movies and tv
shows
she starred in some of the most iconic
movies of all time
including 1971's the last picture show
which earned her an academy award for
best supporting actress
i adore comedy i just
i really i mean i like to do it over and
over again until i just get sick of it
her beloved role on the mary tyler moore
show was only the beginning
phil look i just don't think that i
should be there when you talk to sue
mary you have to be there one you're my
friend
two you will be neutral three if you're
not there
i will rip her face off
i'll go with you it kicked off a
legendary run of television performances
eventually earning her eight emmy awards
it means that i'm here to stay and it
isn't a
flash in the pan and a fly by night and
over the years her career
never seemed to slow down cloris hit the
ballroom in 2008
on dancing with the stars really i can't
tell you i just feel so
this is where i should be and what i
should be doing right now
and i think it's going to be on for a
long time and in 2010
she joined the cast of raising hope and
remained with the series until it ended
after four seasons
in recent years klorus had roles in the
drama american gods
and the reboot of mad about you
it wasn't oh i want to be a star in all
hollywood
ever it was just something that
developed cloris opened up to e.t
many times over the years about her
legendary career
i can't help but put humor into
what i do even if it's serious because i
think
there's i have a silly bone and it
tickles me
the humanness or the foibles that that
each of us has
the the part behind what we think the
world is seeing
the backside is to me the interesting
part i guess it's that movie making
magic that really
keeps you in there really forever
yeah forever
you